there's no
difference between the physiological
response to something that you're
excited about and something that you're
nervous about or that you're dreading
and i guess if people are going to take
away anything from our conversation
today it's that despite these responses
being automatic there are direct control
points through which we can control the
autonomic nervous system meaning that we
can dial down the level of alertness or
increase the level of calmness
that was stanford neuroscientist andrew
huberman and i'm matt abrahams and
welcome to think fast talk smart when we
were looking at episodes to include in
our best of series we found that the
number one episode listeners just like
you kept coming back to was this one
about managing speaking anxiety clearly
this is a challenge we are all facing as
we transition back to more face-to-face
in-person communication many of us are
really feeling nervous
let me bring in jenny luna our executive
producer to introduce this episode more
fully hey matt
this episode with andrew is actually our
most downloaded throughout all four of
our seasons i like that you and andrew
share tactical and practical advice and
i love this notion that if you know more
about how the brain works you can be a
more confident speaker after talking
with andrew jenny i change the way i
think about how i prepare to speak and
address my own jitters he is super
knowledgeable and his huberman lab
podcast is fantastic and it's at the top
of my playlist now like in our other two
summer learning series best of episodes
we have a homework assignment for all of
you and i'm going to ask jenny to share
a little bit more about it sure
you and andrew talk about the importance
of breath work so here's the technique
it's like a three-step process
step one inhale fully as deeply as you
can
step two sip in just a bit more air and
finally
exhale as slowly as possible
repeating this technique just a few
times can really help calm us down and
get us ready for communication
absolutely it's a great technique
alright everybody let's take a deep
breath
relax and enjoy this episode
i am really looking forward to speaking
with andrew huberman who is a professor
in the neurobiology department at
stanford university's school of medicine
andrew's research focuses on
understanding the brain mechanisms
controlling anxiety cognition and
performance under stress
additionally andrew works diligently to
bring neuroscience research to the
public through his teaching his videos
and his hubermann lab podcast which
needs to be in everyone's playlist
thanks for being here andrew shall we
get started
delighted to be here like me i know
you're fascinated by fear in its impact
as we all know communicating in front of
others in high-stakes situations can
certainly involve fear
from a neurologic point of view what's
going on what happens to our voice our
speech and our hand movements when we
get nervous
yeah so when we get nervous
we are entering a state which is
perfectly natural but reflects
one station along what's called the
autonomic continuum
and really the autonomic continuum can
be conceptualized as a continuum between
states of very high alertness think
maximum excitement or fear all the way
down to deep sleep
so that our states of mind and body
are not discrete
entities they are along this continuum
this autonomic continuum so when we are
excited or we are nervous
we have a number of physiological
responses that are
purely autonomic meaning they're purely
automatic
the most important thing to realize is
that it is a continuum
it has some features that are autonomic
meaning automatic
and
that
there's no
difference between the physiological
response to something that you're
excited about and something that you're
nervous about or that you're dreading
and so there's an additional component
there that we need to consider but the
the most important thing of above
all and i guess if people are going to
take away anything from our conversation
today it's that despite these responses
being automatic
there are direct control points
through which we can control the
autonomic nervous system meaning that we
can dial down the level of alertness or
increase the level of calmness those
actually turn out to be two different
things so while it's called the
autonomic nervous system and the
autonomic continuum it's a bit of a
misnomer because there are two specific
levers or entry points that we all have
from birth
that require essentially no learning
there there's you have to know what they
are but that will allow people to
control
voice level of alertness level of
shaking in their hands so it's a quite
remarkable system in that it has this
asymmetry autonomic on the one hand but
with very powerful entry points for
control on the other i want to get back
to the notion that you brought up about
how we uh
experience the physiological arousal
that we get you said in some cases it
it's due to anxiety and fear in other
cases it's due to excitement you know
part of that i think has to do with how
we label what we're experiencing and i
know that there's some research from my
academic field that says one way to help
manage anxiety is just to work on how
you perceive the physiological symptoms
that you're having so if you say hey
even though my heart rate's going up i'm
getting a little sweaty and shaky it's
because i'm excited to share the
information i'm sharing versus oh my
goodness everybody's looking at me and
i'm feeling nervous so part of it i
think has to do with how we frame the
situation is that ring true
absolutely when we are in a state of
alertness whether
because of excitement or fear
the
sympathetic division of the autonomic
nervous system let's just call the
alertness system
deploys a hormone from our adrenal
glands adrenaline and it deploys the
equivalent chemical in the brain where
it's called epinephrine it's actually
the same chemically identical structure
but called two different things because
neuroscientists and physiologists like
to make things complicated
um not simple but the the role of
adrenaline slash epinephrine
is to create agitation in the body
and to create focus in the mind
and this is an important concept because
that agitation makes it harder to be
still which is sort of a duh right
that's the definition of agitation but
it was designed for to move us to
physically
move us so that we would be biased
toward ambulation or bias toward um
shifting what from one position to a new
one and so one of the toughest things
for many people is to tolerate that
level of adrenaline or alertness when
they have to be still the simplest
example i can give of this that i think
most people will be familiar with is if
in the days where we
congregated in person there's this
traditional practice of going around the
room
and introducing yourself and saying
something about what you do and
most people actually find that to be
very stressful especially if they toward
the end of the line now why would that
be right most people know their name and
can say their name most people know what
they do and can say that it's anything
but a high stress circumstance and
occasionally there's some social
pressure where if someone's very funny
before us or they say something
in a particularly nice way then we feel
like some additional pressure to do that
as well but it really has more to do
with the fact that when we're in a room
listening to somebody we can uh we're
comfortable with the fact that we're not
going to speak or walk or do much and we
could just sit there and write or listen
or text or grow whatever it is we have
to do
as
we are called on to say something
the reason it's easier to do early in
the line is because
we are holding on to a reverbatory
circuit there are circuits in our brain
that anticipate action and prepare us
for action and the longer we keep that
in check the more challenging it becomes
when we are with trying to withhold
action but we're preparing for action
there's a lot of re reverberatory excuse
me active activity in our nervous system
and it feels like stress getting ready
to go up to the podium is tough when we
get up to the podium many people
including myself find that if we rock
back and forth a little bit or we can
engage some movement in our body
suddenly we start to relax and that's
because a drunk adrenaline slash
epinephrine was designed to move us and
it wasn't designed to move us in
response to
incoming large predators it was but
that's not its primary function its
primary function was to move us from
whatever position we're into a new
position sometimes towards things
sometimes away from things depending on
whether or not we want the experience or
we want to avoid the experience but the
actual inner experience what we call
interoception our perception of our
internal landscape is identical for
something that we want to approach
versus we want to move away from
absolutely identical below that from the
neck down that is
really interesting so so if you can
reframe the physiological response you
can see it very differently and i find
fascinating that that when we see
somebody who is nervous moving one way
versus the other way as an audience
member we have very different
perceptions so if somebody steps up on a
stage and then takes a step back as
they're starting to speak it looks like
they're retreating and therefore maybe
nervous or shy but if somebody actually
steps forward we have a perception that
they're confident in stepping into the
challenging situation so it's not only
what we perceive it's how the audience
perceives it as well
absolutely it's it might be useful for
people to think about the fact that
there's only three responses we can have
to any circumstance one is to stay still
one is to move forward or one is to move
back
back in 2018 a graduate student in the
neurosciences program who did her thesis
with me lindsay solay and i published a
paper in the journal nature
lindsay discovered a brain circuit
that controls the movement toward
threats now these this isn't the kind of
movement that will get you killed this
is the kind of movement toward a uh in
an intelligent way in an adaptive way
towards something that in this case an
animal or a person wants to do but feels
a tremendous amount of of autonomic
arousal of stress and nervousness about
and the the take-home message is the
following
forward movement under conditions of
anxiety or high levels of alertness aka
stress
triggers the activation of a circuit
deep in the brain that releases the
neurochemical dopamine dopamine of
course is a molecule that is
most commonly associated with a
sensation of reward
and it is released when we achieve
something that we want to achieve but
the other very interesting function of
dopamine is to increase the probability
that we will move toward similar types
of goals in the future so dopamine is
not just the molecule reward it's the
molecule of motivation and drive and so
lindsay's results have a number of
different implications but i think if
people can just conceptualize
that
the anxiety or stress response is the
same as the excitement response they
feel
different because of some top-down
perception or
verbiage that we introduced to it but
they're actually identical
physiologically and that forward
movement provided it's adaptive um
toward a goal triggers the activation of
chemicals in the brain and body that
will make the subsequent pursuit of
those same or similar goals
more likely and more pleasurable
that's really cool so so learning to
take the stage and step forward leaning
in when you're virtual can help and i
believe in some of the work of yours
that i read
it doesn't even you don't actually have
to even physically move if you simulate
movement with your eyes you can have a
similar effect and i'd like for you to
talk about that
back in the early 80s uh someone
actually in palo alto a woman by the
name of francine shapiro is a
psychologist
developed a technique for it was
actually developed for trauma
treatment she was a psychologist did
some work at stanford but also um at a
nearby clinic and essentially what she
had found
uh that taking walks
were was helpful for her anxiety and
stress something that everyone now i
think says okay duh but we always
thought that it was because of movement
of the body but she wanted to import
some of that self-induced relaxation to
her clinic
and she was clever enough to create this
thing that they call emdr eye movement
desensitization reprocessing which
simply involves moving the eyes from
side to side it looks a little goofy if
you see someone do it but moving the
eyes from side to side not up or down
but side to side eye movement actually
triggers we now know suppression of the
amygdala this fear center in the brain
and for years people would ask me about
emdr because i'm a vision scientist and
i work on stress and i thought it was
totally kooky and crazy and i didn't
believe any of it and i
my response was in my mind anyway was
sort of like okay take your emdr and
your magic carpet and
right and head down head down to big sur
and and let's talk later if you want to
talk science but i really i was really
quite wrong because a couple years ago
there were no fewer than five papers
published in very high quality journals
including nature
in mice
non-human primates and humans showing
that these lateralized eye movements
lead to suppression of this fear center
in the brain so it's a quite
long-lasting effect it's i should just
mention if people are going to use it to
deal with actual trauma that should be
done with a real trauma sure
right it works best for specific
circumstances like public speaking it's
not great for sort of reducing your
stress about your entire childhood or
your entire um divorce or your entire
2020. it's it's that's geared toward
specific circumstances but here's how it
works you move your eyes from side to
side for about 30 seconds because it's
actually quite a long time you don't do
this during the event right but that
creates a state of reduced alertness aka
stress
not so much you follow asleep in your
system and then you're able to better
approach things
with more ease and more with less
alertness i've heard you mention on your
podcast that there are two approaches to
addressing stress can you share those
with us
the two approaches are you can either
reduce your stress in real time
things like this eye movements right
before you go into a stressful event
like up on stage or hard conversation or
even if you're just experiencing anxiety
there's a breathing tool i'll share with
you in a moment that's grounded deeply
in physiology as well or
you can raise your stress threshold
so things like ice baths running up
steep mountains um
exposure therapy those are actually
designed to increase your tolerance your
cognitive tolerance for high levels of
agitation in your body increasing the
probability that you'll stay still not
say the wrong thing
um not strike anyone not lose your cool
right
so it's sort of learning to be calm in
storm or what is sometimes referred to
as being comfortable being uncomfortable
that is a distinctly different set of
practices
than things like the eye movements i
described or the second thing which is a
real time tool for calming oneself
that my laboratory is working closely on
with david spiegel's laboratory in the
department of psychiatry
which is we ask the question what
breathing
approach is the best to calm oneself in
real time because meditation is
wonderful tm is wonderful
if you know if you're of drinking age
and you can tolerate it without going
into excess a nice glass of wine is also
another way to activate this
right
so is a massage so is it a dip in this
in the hot tub or a sauna sounds like
you're describing a nice date
right yeah exactly or you know or um
remember it's called the rest and digest
system for a reason one of the most
powerful ways to shift your autonomic
nervous system to one of more calm is to
fill your gut
with
food that then the distention of your
gut sends signals through the vagus
nerve to a little clap set of neurons
right behind your ear called the nodos
ganglia which projects into your brain
gives you a little bit of a dopamine hit
this is well
well established as well as activating
areas of the brain that involved in
calming you down and so you know there
are a lot of ways to control the
autonomy nervous system slowly and
indirectly massage hot tub big meal etc
we're talking about real time control
fast so the best way that we know or
that and this is work that's still in
progress is to use what are called
physiological size so these were
discovered back in the 30s
turns out that when
you are stressed you are breathing less
deeply the most common the most common
advice is to take a deep breath right it
turns out that's exactly the wrong
advice oh no
exhale emphasize breathing leads to much
more rapid activation of the calming arm
of the nervous system
and the it turns out you don't just want
to exhale
you want to do a double inhale so inhale
twice through the nose so inhale through
the nose and then before you exhale
sneak in a little bit more air
and then do a long exhale and you do
this just one to three times so it's you
know inhale
inhale again even if you just sneak the
tiniest bit of air ideally the inhales
are done through the nose and then
exhale through the mouth now why does
this work
turns out that your lungs are not just
two big bags of air
they are
billions
of little tiny sacks called the avioli
of the lungs right those little sacs are
are continue contiguous more or less
with the vasculature with the blood
supply so when you exhale you offload
carbon dioxide and a lot of the stress
responses due to elevated carbon dioxide
in the bloodstream
when if you've ever been to a kid's
party and that you're asked to blow up a
balloon and you blow on the balloon
sometimes it inflates right away but if
it doesn't you give two hard
push uh pushes with air one or two and
the same thing happens with the aviola
of the lungs as we get stressed they
start to collapse
they flatten out and to re-inflate them
the double inhale
brings maximal air into the alveolar
lungs and then you offload the maximum
amount of carbon dioxide when you exhale
so this is very simple very fast you can
actually do it during exercise as well
so if you ever find that your heart is
pounding and you want to calm down
first thing is exhale
then maybe try the double inhale
and then exhale follow
usually at least what we find in our
studies is that within just one to three
of those cycles meaning within about
five seconds
autonomic nervous system starts to shift
more towards calmness and then if you
like you can start using your eye
movements or whatever cognitive
reframing but one of the things that i
think will resonate with people and i
hope it does is that it is very hard to
control the mind with the mind when
you're stepping up to the podium and you
are nervous
you can say oh yeah that nervousness is
actually excitement and i think you know
and this is i must be really agitated
because i really want to do this and but
it in that moment of stress it's very
hard to control what's going on so under
conditions where your mind is not where
you want it
use the body to control the mind
[Music]
so you've just shared techniques for
what we can do when we're directly
experiencing anxiety what can we do to
prepare for anxiety in advance
the other thing to do is the stuff that
you do away from the podium away from
the big event or the hard conversation
and that involves deliberately taking
yourself into states of heightened
alertness
as my colleague david spiegel likes to
say it's not just about the state you
find yourself in it's how you got there
and whether or not you had anything to
do with it and what he's really saying
is that when you drive your nervous
system into a state of high alertness
and you learn to be calm there
you achieve a certain kind of superpower
such that when real life puts you into
those states without any warning and
very fast
you it's like driving in fog the first
time you do it it's scary as heck the
fifth time you do it it's still scary
but you you've been there before and so
you're now a good driver so the way you
do this it can be of different um
you know practices but one of the best
ones is a very cold shower and trying to
stay calm for one to three minutes in a
very cold shower wow it's not something
that i like uh it's not very pleasant
which is
the and there you use a protocol of
breathing that involves taking 25 to 30
deep inhales for reasons that now it
should be obvious right increase your
heart rate
and then big exhale
hyperventilating
you're hyperventilating and by the 25th
one you will be very stressed now i want
to say that if people have our panic
attack prone or anxiety attack prone
this is gonna i do not recommend this
very uncomfortable but then what you do
at the end of that 25 breaths is you
offload
all your air you empty your lungs
and then you sit
for about 15 to
some people can go longer 60 seconds or
so lungs empty
and you try and feel peaceful with that
heightened level of adrenaline in your
body
now never do this near water i want to
be really clear because there is this
thing called shallow water don't even do
it in a puddle right um
because i i don't want anyone injuring
themselves or worse but if you repeat
that for two or three cycles what you
will find it's pretty remarkable there
are a lot of there's some nuance to
these practices but they also kind of
start and end with vision or breathing
right and and i love how you make them
simple for us to understand so the
things we can do in the moment or right
up before the moment of the anxiety and
then there are things we can do to in
essence desensitize ourselves in advance
now we are all communicating in this
virtual world these days
is there anything from your experience
of how eyes work that that would
indicate what we should do for example
people often say you need to look at the
camera so it looks like you're looking
at the person on the other end any
insight you have
about this virtual communication we all
do
uh okay well first of all it's a very
unnatural time because um most of all
because
we are not used to seeing a little
picture of ourselves moving while we
look at other people um everyone's
carrying a little mirror around on their
shoulder for us now in this world so
turn that off or get it out of the way
um because it will interfere with your
presence to the conversation and
um other people's perception of how
present you are the other thing that's
really important is that there's a lot
of research on gaze and eye contact and
frequency of blinking the most powerful
uh way to connect with somebody through
zoom or just in person is actually not
to stare directly at them the whole time
is a combination of direct gaze averting
gaze and closing one's eyes that's you
know a real conversation involves
moments where you're looking away trying
to cr you know
like i'm doing right now i'm trying to
you know grab a concept and say it uh in
a way that makes sense but then also
where we re-engage and so a conversation
is actually a process of of looking
directly at the other person and then
breaking gays and then coming back again
the other thing that works quite well if
people are experiencing eye fatigue
from looking at screens up close and
there's a whole other conversation
is
one thing that works well is to see
someone's face at the beginning say
hello because faces are a powerful um
you know they it collects a lot of
context for the brain saying hello but
then going into pure audio and then
going back to visual before you part
ways that may actually be a more
effective form of zoom communication
than pretending we're all in the same
room and trying to stare at one another
the entire time and sometimes see that
reflection of ourselves and that's
that's advice that that others on this
podcast have given that that you don't
have to show your video the whole time
so before we end andrew i'd like to ask
you the same three questions i ask
everybody who joins me on this podcast
are you up for that
definitely if you were to capture the
best communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would that
be
speak to inform
and teach
not impress oh i like that so it's about
getting the information across and you
are certainly a master at that and i
encourage everybody to search out some
of the work you've done your podcast is
fantastic because you do such a nice job
of something we talked about on an
earlier podcast how to make complex
information accessible you do a great
job of that you certainly don't dumb it
down but you make it accessible as
you've done for us today let me ask
question number two who is the
communication that you admire and why
you know
there are two forms of communication
that really appeal to me and they will
seem at odds with one another uh
i love poetry
because
really great poetry
doesn't really make sense at a
uh cognitive level
it gets to a
kind of what probably is some sort of
deeper universal meaning it probably is
tapping into
brain circuits that are more on a
emotional level or that
reside in the brain body connection i
really believe that so that speaks to
some sort of quote-unquote truth
um so i love poetry and
um
i'm a big wendell berry fan i'm also a
big joe strummer fan you know uh most
famous for being the singer of the clash
for the things he said not while he was
on stage so joe strummer on uh was
brilliant uh
in terms of his um
offstage speech
very people to check out some of the
things that joe said later in his life
were really remarkable insights into
human beings and humanity there's some
real core truth there
and
the in the world of science
claude despond is a
biology professor at nyu who studies
insect
vision
and
the only word that i can use to describe
what it is to hear one of claude's
lectures whether or not you're familiar
with biology or not is pure enchantment
wow
he transports you into a world where
frankly i i don't really care about
dragonfly vision on a regular basis but
when i listen to claude speak i think
about human vision i think about
uh love he talks about the love spots of
the dragonfly eyes that for pursuing uh
mates and food and it's just remarkable
and anyone that can
do that
um for is
incredible but claude is the uh world
heavyweight champion of making biology
inc fascinating and uh delightful well
i'm gonna check his lectures out for
sure last question for you what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
passion
the speaker has to love the topic
an organizational logic there has to be
a
to
the information
it just can't be bullet points and a
beginning middle end kind of thing
and
clarity
you know if people
if people walk away understanding more
than they did at the beginning
then you you've won
it gets back to the the most important
thing to do is to teach your audience
educate them
passion structure and clarity psc we're
going to add that as another acronym to
your list of many acronyms i've heard
you talk about
andrew it was fantastic to have you here
i'm taking a deep breath to calm myself
down from all the exciting information
that you shared thank you so much it is
my true hope that all of us listening in
can apply some of these tools and hacks
to optimize our communication thank you
thanks so much for having me
wow that episode had lots of techniques
we can use to become more comfortable
and confident when we speak
and remember when you start to feel
nervous with your communication you can
always turn to the breath
this has been another episode of our
think fast talk smart summer learning
series please check out all three
episodes in this series think fast talk
smart the podcast is a production of
stanford graduate school of business
this episode was produced by podium
podcast company jenny luna and me matt
abrahams
find more resources follow and join our
conversation on linkedin by searching
think fast talk smart and please
download and follow wherever you get
your podcasts and be sure to drop us a
review on spotify or apple podcasts
you